For me Terrence Malick is a filmmaker that
almost defies discussion.
Analysis of his recent work almost seems antithetical
to the work itself.
None the less, I’m deeply drawn to, and
fascinated by what he’s trying to do.
His exploratory, existentialist style, seems
not to state, but only to search, only to
ask.
He’s not insisting, but inciting
And while his recent work in To the Wonder,
Knight of Cups and Song to Song has enthralled
me, bored me, inspired me and frustrated me,
there exists a quality to his work that is
undeniably unique.
His recent trilogy of film is so thematically
intertwined that footage from each is almost
interchangeable.
Working without a script, these films cast
aside story to become meditations on existence.
Characters change, locations change, but there’s
a consistent searching that remains constant.
He’s making films that consist almost entirely
of the scenes that would be cut out of a conventional
story or film, or used merely as transitional
moments.
He abandons the writer-centrism that pervades
the vast majority of filmmaking, and in doing
so, brings the choices of the actors, cinematographer,
and editor to the forefront.
I think for Malick the process of creation
almost supersedes the final product.
The lens is searching because he is searching,
the characters search because the actors search.
These films aren’t planned, they are formed
by reaction.
The actors react to the world and each other,
the cinematographer reacts to the actors and
to the world, and the editor reacts to the
rhythms constructed by the actors, the world,
and the cinematographer.
The director becomes facilitator, putting
things into motion and then looking for patterns
in that motion.
Maybe these visual obsessions emerge across
his films, not because he has something to
say about windows, architecture, nature, or
sunlight, but because this is what emerges
when being is explored with freedom and curiosity.